hey Daniel how's it going give me one
second I'm just changing my out my mic
out but can you hear me yes yes I can
hear you perfect well I hope your
evening is going well because I'm about
to ruin it you say that every time and
then I beat you and then you dance but I
guess I I guess you're right I feel kind
of pity for beating you every time so
I'll feel a little bad after is that is
that so well you know are we putting
something on the liner are we not doing
that we can we can totally put something
on you know I never say no to that
because I'm so confident it might
perhaps naively but I'm so are you ready
to bet a dance I see your chat is saying
Habibi so maybe if we beat you you have
to freestyle a dance too Habibi
we can do that yeah Bibi is like my
theme song but I but I want energy I
want energy okay
[Music]
okay so what are gonna be fair odds if
we're doing an adoption match like it's
like cuz maybe we will do something
where we have three minutes and you have
how long like 45 seconds 30 seconds we
can do like in the middle between 30 and
45 seconds I think that's what we kind
of did last time
sure that sounds good we can do three
minutes to 40 seconds or 35 seconds is
that fair three minutes to 40 seconds
yeah three minutes to 40 seconds and you
have to adopt us yes sounds that sounds
like very fair eyes to me okay guys here
we go
I'm turning off the check here we go I'm
waiting for both of us to do the odds
okay here we go
you need forty seconds I begin the game
and we are okay before I play
aggressively I'm gonna play my main open
that's it that's the winning cheering go
I can't play chess without my gc3 is
what I usually play how much time we up
I really don't know I meant to say
that's inaccurate well that is a move
but age-3 here is very venomous
establish your g4 well if you're gonna
be negative now I'm gonna be playing
poorly no this is good let me know when
you want to give feedback six I'll take
care of ya yeah sure no I like h6h 6a
they want to go b4 and Knight a four and
there
no-no-no played Queen c7 Alisa uc7 I
want to try to get the 1995 or 95 in a
second spot I like it they've spent
about half the time let's get the night
losing its only pawn structure II but it
stops his threats okay we're gonna move
okay just move away now the White Queen
ee7
let's instead try to get the might
f-bombs hanging pawns again why did you
tell me to hide it you just virtually
see one incoming okay let's just keep
things protected the idea I wanna trade
everything off five forces the Queen now
a for the night to see 508 for I mean
they've got nice nice I mean II can't if
we keep the position blocked can he make
any progress or not he's trying actually
move the bishop move the bishop
yes listen listen Bishop see a nice e6
would be okay good very good smooth game
smooth game
no chances just that's how I want to win
no black games with a month line is
tough to play fast okay
can you not blue sit oh so you don't
screw up theory I know my theory
memorize like the back of my
c5g fun
okay okay bang bang this is a good line
I mean I would prepare before Larry here
it's fine before his idea for before
there's a FICO 96 neither go extinct g4
there is also strong G form basically I
can screaming clock already know
queenship c4 I go for c6
yeah but Queen Queen B's and I'm gonna
be an endgame of upon this I should be
able to convert ideally sure why do you
need play might be five eventually else
too late sure take that's fine we knew
take this first and then h5 is there
yeah hey check sure oh now we're
definitely losing the fun push-ups
okay oh god that was really bad so under
system they play quite well I think
these positions I faith in the game dude
are you gonna give up yes resigns to
zero your ego oh yeah
yeah they got a terrible also G poor is
good
there should be four I'll go Bishop GTO
ok Queen b6 Bishop is gonna get trapped
threatening should be already winning
yellow this theory I can also go roof t1
here to just let us the court wonderin
if they do not have to try to evacuate
the knight actively have six is the best
then I can even castle if I try to tell
you but you never listen to it no
ninety-five doesn't even do anything
let's just go be free they'll go you
know go a knight a for probably again
I'm just not in a hurry to take at night
at age six I want to make sure all the
bases are covered before a or do
anything drastic Queen before would be
annoying here though rook c8 and I
Castle because now they give another
piece three now no matter what you need
first like sf5 then I'm gonna take on
deep fire okay they managed to alright
push it out of this morning maybe Kings
better this is coming in with
devastating effect
this is completely winning so let's not
screw this up why cc6 whoops I never
wonder the night nice wait not bad but
not good
she knocks something alone because I
blunder in the night like that really do
not miss a thing do they okay let's play
fast I like focus yep take the bone
queen chick you always this I'm really
alone please
how does this happen every time you what
I have 40 seconds you're freaking me out
why are you freakin on allow eat seven
push ricky-ricky time 6 you have 27
seconds es6
we're fine draw even wins yeah we got
this don't give the Queen yeah Mon says
wrong but I had to adopt them ah yeah
nature yeah I've seen these odds that's
just impossible
all right rub it in his face drunk guys
you said he could beat us yeah I'm
handsome every time I beg to just play
like a sports you know how many but it
is night possible he always beats
himself up after is bad okay I guess I'm
dancing pushes probably gets probably
too much confidence goes bad dr. la No
all right good game good game zai zen
huh
all right yeah I think it was just
supportive
that's insane or if he's just the
world's best dancer hey I don't think
it's not mind uh I don't think it's that
one wanted this ain't a hole anybody is
apartment it was a badly decorate that I
reserved but the little troph an empty
true find it this angle what is this
camera angle Stanford Graduate on its
finest
[Music]
since happy sees happy it's not very
coordinated document that home on a
little field of flowers you know
peaceful oh there we go
that's pretty good it's not devalue do
the gentle walk of course it's all a
chest props he doesn't have anything
else near him chances a knuckle walk Oh
God
oh there you guys is juggling
Oh No is Bailey oh no no no not that not
the throat oh okay I was very graceful
very graceful is literally like karate
everything he touches you see salsa what
do I don't know yeah thanks rich
shouting come on guys
his best work so far he runs around in
and out of the camera so like he's
always running around for something like
[Music]
what is that he's showing it to us what
but he just pretended to eat it I don't
know he's like really you're talking man
I don't know what it is he's getting his
party up for today look Philip the
passion is but a good effort he's
fitting in great efforts a master of
seduction and idea
Meredydd steeped opa the pillows are a
nice touch
no Jackie Chan of dancing using the
entire room yes doesn't do bad oh wait
Dom hasn't been watching the video that
uses props or did you yeah I think in
the video I wrongly decided to just use
props I'm just no
but the I don't know it is I don't know
this is from a video just is on touch at
this point I can't Sal dude everyone
that's just coming in his chat to come
on Big Finish he's falling for theory oh
my god
oh the dude behind the video poured
water on himself
oh we should have pull over the video
side by side also ballon geela oh no I
think eat something I don't see it
getting bad you know and again sorry in
advance if I miss anything
okay good okay here we go yeah we are
gonna watch this point of view open it's
my line can I go for just kind of not
blown or anything do you want to play or
what no I don't have one that I know I
just can't play whatever yeah Jonas
which no I have some ideas okay
you can't look okay if you want you can
switch now um you have done much better
thank you it's pretty simple play give
you an a5 b5 b5 here I don't know if I
like it thanks Bremen c5 just not get I
mean they're just not making mistakes is
not nothing evidence yeah yeah
but what if he retreats his night yeah
they are better than you okay
wow I feel so that's gonna be an LS F in
a good way no come on please Negreanu
maybe the bishop I'm definitely better
you have to think the bishop I okay this
is very strong they take my queen we've
got to find King away which is a
difficult okay take the Queen okay nice
boat says gambit in the caller thank you
for the continuing gifts up they boat
does give me that yourself as well now I
can read off the subs because this is
pretty safe win nice one
okay I got to change things up against
the London because I am NOT playing
other Kings Indian I don't like that I
know exactly what's the joke given the
plan to play the one in blindly the best
way to play against the blind London as
I call it as this system we need seven
and then Knight age six pretty bended no
don't do that that seems wrong yeah
Queen see who's gonna lose hanging d5
here I think I'm not ye if I was gonna
lose I think you have to push d5 yeah d5
is never I think we need to take in push
I'd rather do sure take in push but we
have to be if he told me in sixth grade
that I'd be dancing in front of a 1,700
people I would like not believe you I
you have to understand how far I
wouldn't be dance elect to be which is
uh really helps me break out of my shell
yeah this is good I'm up on already
just to makes me for the night to come
back at some point we take this no don't
take I really want them to impersonate
me I want to get my c5 or King back it's
probably safer right traits we must find
out upon oh maybe seven or no no
anything
this is winning but yeah they go rugby
to again I'm gonna take it queen jeez no
yes you guys play with f1 the a play
with Ricky one coming yeah it's just
winning yeah he played it really really
behind I threw me off yeah I think um
but I think maybe we can try to do a
sleep while we play and then I will
definitely win I'm guaranteed to win if
I do it we felt impression I will
definitely win the game to win the same
okay what if we try to dope defect in
this position and then we can write the
P and kappasagat oh yeah but many
[ __ ] odds here
okay um you play opening sure okay
Smokies I don't know it's open just
positional pressure here's what I'm
going for
good just boring position I got to grind
them down that's really the I think the
mo just a double on the C file bore them
to death and then we'll wait see to see
one crash through it's the idea yeah but
he can't take clear by okay like here I
had b5 yeah yep yes yes look chase you
think oh no no no no no it's bad lord
about defending Brooks e7 incoming is we
need to choose another idea not easy
nothing against them as easy as
literally so difficult to make any
progress he's gonna play Queen g4 crazy
prophylaxis but still I have the safe
one which is so strong yeah okay rogue
defends f2 nice um once again a threat
see there now here that was bad
take they go Bishop d6 but should pay
through in Queen c2 can have enough to
win this yeah I display faster yes 17
seconds we think we do yeah sure you
know go for some trade like he's trying
to move me know why he's gonna meet on
g8 otherwise yeah should be quite easy
for 13 seconds this never is they're so
resilient here's 12 seconds you know
that bond you okay he's like sure pushy
five pushy 545 over here no time by the
way check blood yeah but that's why we
did he five
but it's not gonna make a difference oh
my voice
would eat three movies three oh please
okay
that was tough all right we have to [ __ ]
three losses no that was a crazy good
game but above all hey hey get in
alright okay let me let me fix this
clock yeah let's do the same thing I
just did we only have two more engines
he's gonna play the same weird line you
know it's three seconds to spare honey
sixes in profit should've played
something else actually basically
delaying e5 until more opportune moments
I like 92 by letters he's gonna push
here - she's late right now okay I can
push or no this London is so much like
the position he's been blocked push
again yeah it's gonna give him this
square but it doesn't matter details but
what about here
no I anyway I'll allow them to take in
order to open up a file that's the whole
idea
okay you want the knife in attack right
orange ib3 is also a good move sure
think it would find it I don't believe
that's right whatever their King is so
we and this Bishop is coming in okay
three same defensive resource well where
are we gonna go here yeah missed that
researcher g 1/2 times okay here and if
they interrupted eat soon
just by mg to please take this is still
winning yeah bastard it's fine ocean we
did it beyond us you want to take
garnish sure I see some in this room
and they are playing out of their minds
er and I've never seen them played as
well trying my best but they're very
short of time that's the price they paid
for playing so well and they blender the
roof and that's gonna be for another row
[Music]
this is the critical game you guys all
right it's time to focus it's time to
focus this is a pretty game we can do
Alex where we've been
okay are you going to play the opening
or what yeah no but he's gonna please
weird oh I can play I can play against I
can play inside all right let's go
are you ready focus all right yeah this
is basically classical easy last game
okay we're gonna play e4 and then we're
gonna play we're gonna play an opening
aimed against Andrea's line [ __ ] [ __ ]
he's gonna play I don't know this I
don't know if I can I can't play g6 like
you want to go for b4 b5 my idea here
and then push again oh you haven't
positionally has is the key I think
they're super strong super alert no we
don't want that now we want aged Forbush
basically we need not have to beat this
Bishop King h2 this Chris ring
do you want to play it i.e 6 no cuz he's
gonna attack it's fine little sheepies
96 sure go
oh sorry I didn't see that how 95 is a
big threat okay
95 is actually huge he doesn't have any
weight this is by the way Queen jig for
winning a piece oh they have Bishop d8
seriously wow what an idea
now Queens you suck on Bishop f5 they
were strong and missing chances fine
fine okay now let's just yeah deeply
strong play Katie blocks for good yep or
no Jaffar is my idea you need a way to
do but it's a closed position but he's
gonna go dbg for g5 he's going to meet
you guys we're fine wicked okay should
we keep it close he's gonna play Queen
h5 in sack on h6 yeah I don't see a
defense mr. Queen h5 Bishop h6 and may
and they can do whatever the hell they
want they can take on d5 on e4 they can
they can do whatever they want here but
I think it's me here sure you have to
defend the rook or they found it
offensive yeah holy smokes what a
defense possible
how many pieces am I gonna have to
include here but this has got to be
crushing this has got to be crushing you
and I've got a lot of times yeah no I'm
not gonna give them any chance to share
this is gonna be nice all right that's
about a game really rough okay now all
right good games games Alexandria go
full camera just bits Thank You Chuck
let me let me turn there stream on okay
okay all right I've got to watch their
impersonations before I go oh here we go
JJ's good games thank you and now the
answer for the entertainment no I gotta
go guys in like five minutes I cannot do
the full adoption match so they've won
the real match let's be clear
ready exam knee
mater this is exactly what we practice
[Music]
[Music]
bbl Obinna that's basically it
really I don't know how to even gets a
dark mud ya Habibi yalla bina no I
texted it in their stream hey Carissa
that's hilarious
well I didn't draw faces that's so funny
hilarious basically me thank you Rachel
alright alright goes that goes did we
miss we didn't have the chest clock
that's okay you're good house decent
I'll give them a B+ for that